that should loosen you up sweets Sir
James M Barrie's speaking about charm
once said that it was that quality of
which if a woman did not have it it
didn't matter what else she had in our
industry there is one item which if we
don't have it it doesn't matter what
else we do have it's obvious of course
that we're talking about the camera the
nominations for best achievement in
cinematography are the French Connection
Owen royzman the last picture show
Roberts your teeth Nicholas and
Alexandra very young summer 42 against
Robert circus and the winner is the
winner is
Oswald Morris
accepting the award is producer-director
Norman Jewison
I I wish icing was here at night he's
working on a picture with Robert bolt in
England all I can say is that it was
seven months together and I must say
that it is true he shot the whole
picture through a ladies silk stocking
god bless you I see you really are a
very talented man and I'm sure you would
like to thank the Academy for this great
honor thank you very much